usd ist der kalender und es rappelt im
kasten doch die werbung hallo leute hier
ist wieder eure nie mit links gemacht
alle leute hier ist wieder eure mal wann
wir kamen zu einem neuen adventskalender
auspackt video bedeutet ich habe es
geschafft sie hat mich gefragt ob ich
ihren adventskalender auspacken da ich
würde sagen das macht mich offiziell zum
adventskalender aus profi und
anerkannten experten für kleine
verpackungen mit großem unheil wenn
keine buttons drin heute packen wir den
hscei adventskalender aus es ist wie der
letzte adventskalender so eine art
spielzeug adventskalender nur dieses mal
für erwachsene und die challenge dieses
mal ist vielleicht nicht gut zu werten
denn ich bin 26 jahre alt und erwachsen
und ich kann über erwachsenen spielzeuge
reden ohne büchern ja hier sind 25
sinnliche überraschungen drin im 24
türchen und wir machen diese natürlichen
auf denn es soll ja auch noch eine
überraschung für euch sein wenn ihr euch
den gestellt und findet ihr den link in
der beschreibung danke euch dass ihr mit
mir kooperieren volt und ich würde sagen
wir fangen jetzt an ich habe den premium
adventskalender und der kostet 149 euro
99 und hat einen wahren wert von 900
euro das ist christian gibt es aber noch
den deluxe adventskalender und der
kostet 79 99 und hat einen wahren wert
von 550 euro der diesel
der ist für singles und paare inklusive
lims firepro zwei hochwertige eis de of
toys ich bin mal gespannt 24 türchen mit
25 überraschungen kommt man sogar zwei
okay und wenn ihr gleich auf ein weg
gehen wollt dann habe ich auch einen
rabattcode für euch mal eine 30 damit
bekommt ihr und 30 auch die ganzen
spielsachen ausgeschlossen ist natürlich
der adventskalender weil der schon im
vergleich sehr günstig ist und da mehr
als man kauft und natürlich auch
aktionsartikel und bücher die sind auch
ausgeschlossen aber als andere bekommt
ihr leistet prozent weniger juli hat
geregelt
so jetzt machen wir aber das erste
türchen auf typische nummer eins es ist
so witzig dass erwachsenenspielzeug also
ganz deutlich das könnte auch aus einer
folge black mirror sein oder wenn ihr
blick nur geschaut habe war sie mit 16
von der mutter von meiner besten
freundin und deswegen habe ich schon
erfahrung damit wie man solche sachen
testet über gärten und handschellen bis
hin zu vibratoren und natürlich dildos
vor anderen menschen wird catherine wenn
du dich entscheiden muss so batterien
rein also unseren spielzeug zu testen
legt man sich das auf die nase damit
kann man auf der video machen wenn so
ein ding in der tasche los gehen würde
könnte man heute sagen dass das handy
ist um ein wecker klingelt also das hat
mehrere stufen und geht ganz schön ab
wenn ich das so sagen ich habe auch
informationen dazu bekommen
diesmal bin ich hier richtig vorbereitet
das ist ein auflege vibrato hinlegt man
darauf verwies das prinzip versteht ja
erste türchen
ich wurde nicht enttäuscht küchen nummer
zwei das ist groß
das war okay ich meine es ist eine
premium wenn es länder da sind sachen
für 900
einfach nein das bist du okay also
wirklich das könnte doch jetzt auch so
einen sohn
nein das sieht aus wie eine maus das ist
wirklich aus wie dem ausdrückt das ist
auch so eine maus hier draufklicken
zeltes fireman vibration okay das ist
für den mann also ich weiss nicht falls
in den sets fire noch nicht kennt ist
ein sehr tolles gerät und ich wusste
auch nicht dass es für männer auch ein
es gibt jetzt irgendwie lustig ist
fertig mit gamer maus oder sonst zimmer
kommt ja ich sofort nach jahren
begeistert auf ladekabel kann ich das
mein bruder schenken
aber klar müssen sie auch was vielen man
raus bringt das so ungefähr dass sich
frauen in celles feier bekommen die man
ich bin ja für gleichberechtigung auch
im schlafzimmer was kann der hat 648
bewertungen und viereinhalb von fünf
herzen das ist gut ergonomische form mit
krustige eröffnung ich liebe wie solche
sachen beschrieben werden super
kraftvolle motor in einfache handlung
das ist schön gut also es funktioniert
durch vibration ich demonstriere das mal
ganz kurz 14 vibrations- stufen hat es
gemacht so hält gut und dann ach ja und
dann wird beim zocken deiner hand gleich
ein megahit passiert es ist so ein guter
massiere für die hand also eine
vibrierende maus also ich wusste nicht
dass es für männer gibt aber schön es
hat gerade über mir vibriert der nachbar
bohrt ja das nächste türchen dass wir
auch machen dürfen ist die nummer sechs
nikolaus was bekommen wir an nikolaus
ich bin 26
hallo mama hat sie die zitty ein
weihnachtsgeschenk mit ich das sieht auf
jeden fall nicht nach black mirror aus
da erkennt man sofort was es sein soll
ich hoffe das ist so einer der sich kurz
batterien gefunden und ab die post
[Musik]
bewegen sie wirklich also der macht auf
jeden fall so kreisende bewegung nimmt
es ist so witzig dass man sehen kann was
das hin zu techniken aus dem ring gott
das ist der rempelt wissen wir woher ich
den kenne ich war in london in einem
comedy club und dann hat eine
zuschauerin über den rabbit geredet weil
irgendwie der comedy typ gefragt hat was
ist der beste vibrator man dann hat sie
gesagt david und ich wusste nicht was
gemeint ist das ist der witz an scheint
ist es für manche leute der beste
vibrator also ein türchen nummer ganz
entspannt ich lasse mir nichts anmerken
haben wir einen goldenen bad clark mit
rubin steigt also der welt eingeflossen
und dann hast du hinten einen roten
rubinstein und das ist ein gutes gefühl
und wir machen weiter mit türchen nummer
ich hätte kelly glaub ich gebraucht für
dieses video kelly gegenüber chf shades
of grey gesehen habt bitte macht keine
gäste fand und bestrafe ich euch das ist
eine so genannte
deutsche oder wie die ice t profis sagen
würden eine peitsche erhöhen
[Musik]
nochmals eine peitsche gute qualität das
kann man auf jeden fall sagen sehr
hochwertig aus damit hat man viel spaß
türchen nummer elf massageöl mit
karamell durch hochwertiges massageöl
für gefühlvolle anwendungen kühl trocken
und sonnig geschützt aufbewahren menge
menschen verteilen einmassieren ich bin
liebe keine artikel mehr noch ein
bisschen besser gewesen
oh mein gott du riechst mc sunday mit
karamellsoße hama wo man das richtig
lecker ein schönes design tolles
technisch ca
die muss man ja sagen das muss ja so
sicher verpackt sein weil das ja
hygienisch sauber sein muss
ich weiß was es ist oder yahoo das ist
eine fernbedienung und dafür ist etwas
was du dir ein führen kannst geht doch
das fürst wie ein
und dann kann sie zum beispiel dein
partner fernbedienung geben und dann
macht er halt anwenden möchte was gab es
da habe ich auch bei 5 alles noch schön
mit batterien befüllen ja natürlich
einmal 17
das habe ich auf der wilde party denn
ich glaube es ist das ist also hier seht
ihr einen christbaumschmuck das sind
nämlich
liebeskugeln und die wie fühlst du dir
ein
und die sind praktisch wenn du zum
beispiel schon mal ein kind bekommen
hast und dein kind rausgekommen dann
kann es ja sein dass du ein bisschen
ausgedehnt bist da unten und wenn du das
benutzt also sd 1 führst dann werden
deine muskulatur n' roll hat es könnte
auch sein dass man sie für ein anderes
ende benutzt du mir gerade nicht so ganz
sicher auf jeden fall gibt es auch so
eier die duh benutzen kannst damit deine
muskulatur wieder gestärkt wird und
falls du ein kind bekommen hast
jetzt sind wir schon bei türchen 23 ist
so schade dass wir nicht alle türen
aufmachen können aber ich kann auch
verstehen dass man halt die überraschung
behalten möchte und nicht alles bei land
will das ist orgasmus deal intensiviert
die befriedigung der frau
dieses öl und fettfreie medizinische
gleich viel auf wasserbasis ist haut und
schleimhaut verträglich kondom geeignet
und rückstandsfrei mit wasser abwaschbar
es ist kein empfängnisverhütungsmittel
wichtig und bietet auch keinen schutz
vor infektionen bei kinderwunsch nicht
oder nur sparsam einsetzen da die
empfängnis erschwert werden könnte
bei anwendung mit kondom das gleich gilt
auf das amt abgewürgt
[Musik]
falls sie das kennt man die kommentare
auf das wirkt kann ich zu diesem
zeitpunkt gerade noch nicht sagen so
jetzt sind wir leider leider schon beim
türchen 24 angekommen und ich bin mega
gespannt was man an weihnachten bekommen
für ein sinnliches weihnachtsfest ist
aber echt gut ich habe das gefühl dass
es wirklich für singles und für paare
ist natürlich wenn ich jetzt als frau
mit den adventskalender kaufe und ein
männer gerät drin habe dann hat man
bestimmt jemanden den man das schenken
könnte oder man wartet bis man wieder
ein partner hat und wenn man zum
beispiel halt jetzt lesbisches und dafür
gar keine verwendung hat dann kann man
sich auch einfach verschenkt jedoch
alles an weihnachten werden will sich
belohnt also meine beste freundin kennt
das ich kenne ein anderes als freundin
kennt das ja leute das ist derzeit ist
feier
lustigerweise immer wenn ich ein
bisschen angetrunken bin erkläre ich
meinen ganzen männlichen freunden was
hättest feier ist oder auch meinen
weiblichen freundin aber meistens den
männern bei die das überhaupt nicht
kennen deshalb das feuer ist kein
vibrator sondern er saugt halt an einer
stelle saugen sehr gut tut
du hast ja ich hab mal ja und das ist
was er macht
so und der sagt oh mein gott es also der
feuerwehr sowie breitkopf teil kann man
es abgemacht
also wenn ihr das gefühl hat dass er
eine frau seit die nicht irgendwie
kommen kann oder nur sehr schwer
dann sage ich euch mit diesem gerät
werdet ihr lernen dass auch ihr kommen
könnt es ist unbesetzt das gerät worüber
alle frauen mittlerweile reden weil es
halt einfach ja irgendwie so eine ganze
welt verändert hat
[Musik]
okay was haben wir denn jetzt hier alles
in denen türchen drin gehabt also man
kann auf jeden fall sagen dass die
adventskalender sich definitiv lohnt man
bekommt für sein geld wirklich etwas und
ich bin zufrieden
ein bisschen mich der auch an sailor
moon wisst ihr was ich meine
macht es mondes wie meinst wohl bei der
macht des sportplatzes und als letzte
überraschung für euch darf ich sogar
zwei premium adventskalender von eis de
verlosen dafür müsst ihr nur dieses
video kommentieren mit dem hashtag es
rappelt im kalender und meinen kanal
natürlich abonnieren alle weiteren
teilnahmebedingungen findet ihr in der
infobox da könnt ihr das nachlesen dort
findet ihr auch den link wie ihr zu eis
de kommt und ansonsten wünsche ich euch
eine fröhliche weihnachtszeit wenn ich
so an fans kennen da kommt sicher ich
habe hier noch ein paar und ich hoffe
euch das video gefallen wenn ja dann sex
mit dem daumen nach oben
ich bin sehr fettig möchte unbedingt
wissen was jetzt in den nächsten tagen
vielleicht mache ich jetzt auf oder ich
über die überraschung mehr weiß als de
ist in der kiste
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir auch das gemacht wir
sind beste freunde
wir haben ein pony kann man sehen
danke als de für die kooperation